previously on AI adventures we looked at
collab as a great way to get started in
the data science and machine learning
world but there are some models out
there that need to run for a long time
or you want to get more memory or GPUs
how can we hook up collab with some more
compute power stay tuned to find out
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to use
Google cloud platforms deep learning VMs
to power your collab environment a few
episodes ago we looked at how to create
deep learning VMs with your choice of
machine learning frameworks today we'll
use that VM and connect collab to it so
we can utilize the resources on that
machine to start out will of course need
to make our vm and let's make it a big
one head on over to the cloud
marketplace and we'll find the deep
learning vm and select it ok now to
select our parameters let's give it a
name say collab - box and for good
measure we'll do 8 no 16 CPUs and how
about 60 gigs of memory and now for the
GPUs let's choose the V 100's and we'll
have two of them yeah
now we're really cooking while we're
waiting for that to spin up let's talk a
bit about how we're going to get collab
to talk to your VM there are two tricks
that we're going to use which together
make this connection possible the first
is that collab can actually connect to
any local runtime so if you have a local
Jupiter notebook server running say on
your laptop you can use collab if you
want as your front end to that server
rather than the usual Jupiter notebook
front end and you can access that in the
upper right hand menu of collab the
second trick that will take advantage of
is that you can do port forwarding on
the deep learning VM which is created so
it can be accessed from your local
machine you can do that with the command
shown here and be sure to run it from
your actual local terminal on your
machine and not in say cloud shell in
this particular situation since we wish
to port forward to our local machine
actually running the command in cloud
shell doesn't really achieve our goals
we don't need a port forward to the
cloud shell typically having this port
forwarding set up would just mean that
we can access the Jupiter server from a
local front end but if we open up colab
and tell it to connect to our local
runtime that local runtime will in fact
be the port forwarded one from deep
learning VM and thus the two become
connected so now when you hook the two
together we can see that yes indeed we
have our two v 100 GPUs running and
accessible from our collab front end so
now you understand how collab and deep
learning VMs can work together and how
to get your setup just so based on how
your needs are changing both in terms of
what the front end looks like and what
back-end system is driving it for
example you can develop against a local
back-end initially and then when you
want to get more power move up to the
deep learning VM so how do you set up
your data science around it and how do
you allow us to change flex and grow as
needed let me know in the comments below
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures and if you enjoyed
it be sure to like and subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right when they
come out for now head over to the deep
learning VMs and try connecting it with
your collab notebook
[Music]